olá pessoal boa noite é eu queria
compartilhar com vocês
três aspectos que eu considere o
seguinte pontos na minha vida e que se
assentam num tripé o primeiro vértice
deste tripé o tripé do querer e ele me
remete um pouco a minha infância ea
época de escola pelo que vocês podem ver
né eu sou de uma época em que a escola é
principalmente a a escola pública ela
não era uma escola em que todos nós
tínhamos direito
ela era uma escola para poucos e eu
fazia o ensino primário e na no bairro
onde eu morava na verdade existiam do
dois tipos de escola uma escola que é
essa que é a escola primária e que ela
na verdade destinado àquelas pessoas que
conseguiram entrar na escola mas que
pertence a uma classe social mais baixa
e uma outra escola que tinha próximo que
era uma escola da considerada uma escola
de uma classe mais favorecido porque na
verdade ela tinha no ginásio e tinha o
que naquela época era o clássico
científico hoje o ensino médio e é
destinado aos alunos de famílias mas
melhores situadas econômica e
socialmente
eu estudava nessa escola que era escola
primária e naquele ano e uma escola que
abrir é o espaço por ginásio só que por
aqui a gente pudesse continuar os nossos
estudos nós temos que passar por um
processo seletivo que se chamava o
processo de admissão
nós agora denuncia idade mesmo né é e aí
nesse processo
nós tínhamos é quem podia pagar um custo
nem fazia então esse curso de admissão
ele era um curso que se dava no período
contrário ao período de aulas e nós
tínhamos aula diariamente de história
geografia língua portuguesa e matemática
eu vim de uma família basicamente
criar caos a minha mãe na verdade ficou
casada só o tempo necessário para teu e
meu irmão mais velho e quando ela enviou
ela voltou pra casa da minha avó que na
verdade já era viúva pela segunda vez e
tinha três filhos pequenos também para
criar as duas minha avó era analfabeta
minha mãe mal tinha terminado o segundo
ano primário em ambas acreditavam e me
faziam acreditar também é que de fato
isso ao longo do tempo se mostrou se é
verdade que a escola era o único meio de
ascensão o que nós tínhamos na época e
ela se empenharam muito e com a baixa
qualificação que tinha
elas eram empregadas eram lavadora de
roupa e minha mãe posteriormente foi
operário de fábrica e é com esse
dinheiro que elas ganhavam que elas
acabaram conseguindo me pagar essas
aulas extras para que eu pudesse fazer o
curso de admissão
nesse nesse período de uma professora
que era uma professora de matemática não
bastava seja de matemática era uma
professora também que costumava quando
subi da minha pretensão de prestar o
exame para outra escola que não aquela
na qual eu estava matriculada começou a
mostrar pra mim para os demais colegas
da classe da minha impossibilidade disso
é bem sucedido no exame que prestaria e
foi um ano bastante difícil porque o
tempo todo assim os meus equívocos dos
meus erros
eles eram apontados como sempre assim
pra mostrar que eu não teria condições
de ser bem sucedida bom infelizmente ou
felizmente isso não aconteceu e eu
acabei passando foi uma das primeiras
colocadas
e aí a minha vida teve um outro percurso
e se essa história que eu contei pra
vocês
ela marca muito esse tripé que o tripé
do querer do dos aspectos que são
importantes e significativos para mim na
minha vida então querer e querer
bastante alguma coisa
o tempo foi passando e aí eu me vi no
outro momento também que foi entre o
momento de escolha de uma profissão e
é verdade até por volta de 30 anos que é
onde 60 o segundo triplo é que é o tripé
do fazer
é nessa época principalmente na minha
época por ser um olhar também que as
pessoas sempre dizem o que é que a gente
tem que fazer tem que escolher uma
profissão tem que ser bem sucedido tem
que casar tem que ter filhos ou seja tem
que resolver uma série de questões num
prazo muito curto isso algumas décadas
atrás até se justificava porque a nossa
média de vida era muito baixa então é
preciso que a gente vive intensamente
resolvesse tudo até uns 30 40 anos que
logo em seguida a gente a morrer aí foi
nesse período então que dando
prosseguimento aos estudos
eu acabei prestando vestibular não sabia
muito bem na época nem o que eu estava
fazendo
até porque eu não tinha uma família não
tinha quem pudesse orientar sobre a
escolha de uma profissão
o que a gente sabia que era feito era
ser professor
então resolvi que ia ser professora
lembra até hoje assim parada na frente
da era umas banquinhos umas carteirinhas
de escola que a gente sentava para fazer
o vestibular eu sou de são paulo e aí eu
prestei hoje é fuvest na época no
vestibular para a usp e tinham as
cadeirinhas assim que a gente escolher a
profissão pela filhinha
aí eu prestei o vestibular para letras
na usp e prestei o vestibular de
pedagogia na puc e acabei passando sendo
aprovada nos dois e preferi fazer
pedagogia
não porque eu soubesse o que foi sua
pedagogia mas por que ir e vir da minha
casa para a faculdade era muito mais
tranqüilo ir pra porque afinal de contas
eram só duas horas e meia de ônibus para
ir e duas horas e meia de ônibus para
voltar para quem trabalhava o dia
inteiro fazia faculdade à noite e depois
retomava a rotina foi nesse período que
na verdade eu também fui descobrindo o
que era educação e fui não conhecia a
profissão a priori mas foi aos poucos
conhecendo aos poucos eu fui me
envolvendo então fui sendo professora de
educação infantil professora
o de ensino fundamental e ensino médio
graduação pós graduação e também vive
outras possibilidades de outras facetas
dessa carreira foi diretora foi
coordenadora pedagógica dona de escola
assessora educacional e por aí vai
é essa essa esse momento da minha vida
ele marca muito bem essa coisa de fazer
o fazer intensamente aquilo que você se
propõe e outro tripé que marca a minha
vida é o tripé da paixão me apaixonar
incondicionalmente e entregará uma
paixão eu descobri com a maternidade que
também não era uma coisa que em
princípio eu quisesse até porque eu tive
meu primeiro filho usando o dilson uma
segunda filha usando um contraceptivo
importado ea terceira filha fruto de uma
laqueadura
mas foi mas na verdade foi o que me
possibilitou poder vivenciar o vértice
da paixão
eu não amo os meus filhos todos da mesma
forma nem amigos nem mesmo do mesmo
jeito e nem com a mesma intensidade o
tempo todo mas na convivência com eles
eu fui também me permitindo r vivenciar
e experimentar os diferentes facetas da
paixão e e apaixonar novamente ea todo
instante nunca sendo do mesmo jeito mas
sempre de um jeito diferente
o que essas três coisas têm em comum é o
querer fazer ea paixão eu gostaria de
trazer para a nossa pré um pouco para
essa reflexão uma frase de clarice
lispector com de lá diz o seguinte sonho
o que você quiser seja o que você quiser
seja faça o que você quiser fazer porque
você só tem uma vida e é provável que
você só tenha uma chance de fazer aquilo
que você quer a essas palavras eu
gostaria também de juntar as palavras da
cora coralina
quando ela diz o seguinte eu não sei se
a minha vida é curta ou longa demais
eu só sei que a minha vida só tem
sentido se ela tocar o coração das
pessoas a essas duas positivas
eu gostaria de acrescentar o seguinte
mais do que tocar o coração das pessoas
é importante tocar o nosso coração
então se tem uma coisa que a vida tem me
ensinado é justamente isso é preciso que
a gente busque a coerência entre o
querer e o fazer mas mais do que isso é
preciso que a gente se apaixone por
aquilo que a gente quer e por aquilo que
a gente faz isso é alguma coisa que eu
tenho pra dizer aqui pra vocês hoje é o
seguinte que era muito estabeleça muitos
objetivos faça intensamente para que
eles aconteçam mas se apaixona
nem que seja de mancini inicialmente mas
loucamente enquanto você vivenciar esse
processo só desse jeito eu acredito que
a fila que a vida vale a pena
muito obrigada